good afternoon everybody I'm Tom Paul
I'm the Dean of the Graduate School and
Molecular siren devel
biology and one of the pleasures of this
job is to pick out interesting members
of our faculty to address the company of
scholars lectures and our lecture today
is Catherine Katie Lofton who I got to
know when she was promoted to associate
professor last year that's my talent
scouting activity studying on all the
promotion's committees and she had such
a striking outstanding case I had to get
to know her better so I'm I've invited
her to give this talk Katie is an
associate professor of Religious Studies
and of American Studies she graduated
from the University of Chicago with
honors and both of those fields in 2000
and received her PhD from the University
of North Carolina in Chapel Hill in 2005
and then I don't know the story but she
wandered around a bit from read to
Indiana to Princeton before with short
stints in each of those places and
wandering the desert before she came to
Yale as an assistant professor in 2009
and she was promoted last year to
associate professor in 2012 so one of
the things I learned about her is that
she's a fabulous teacher so I knew she'd
be great for this lecture the story goes
that the least in her promotion case was
that she offered a certain course that
ballooned in its second year of offering
to be the biggest course in her
department overnight so she must have
done something right her scholarship is
in the area of the history of American
religion and the theory of religion and
culture and along this line she's
written a book that's received quite a
bit of attention on Oprah the the gospel
of an icon that's not what she's going
to talk about today it she's going to be
talking about religion and the practice
of American parenting and so we're
looking forward to remarks after her
remarks we'll have a question and answer
period and then we'll have a reception
in the common room next door Haiti thank
you so much tom you're like the William
Morris of Yale University right now and
I'm really honored
to get to do this and I'm going to talk
to you about a subject that I've been
working on for about a year it's a
project that's really unfurling for me
and I really welcome in the Q & A
comments things that you free-associate
this is the beginning to me of an
argument as my students know I have a
problem with speaking very very quickly
and so if I don't try to restrict myself
through the prose on the page you will
have a very hard time tracking my excess
so to that end I use the mechanism of
PowerPoint as sort of a highlights reel
to accompany alongside my own excessive
verbosity the subject I want to talk to
you today is in some ways very much
connected to all the subjects that I
mean these are all subjects on which I
have written at some point or another
and in some ways there's this kind of
excessive multiplicity to the thing that
I am venturing in in this multiplicity I
am trying to name the religious now I
work simultaneously against the
secularization thesis and within it as I
am invested in the naming of certain
perpetual desires and social forms as
religious while I'm also a scholar of
what is not perpetual how Americans are
religious now is quite different than
they were in 1890 yet I argue we are all
still religious naming what remains and
what has changed is my work so I am here
to study what focuses our existence what
defines our concept of the social and
what drives us to differentiating
rituals and identities this vocabulary
is I argued that of the study of
religion what makes the study of
religion somewhat different those since
those previous attributes could be a
scientist sociology or philosophy but I
argue what is different about religion
the study of it the practice of it is
the obsession with the other religions
describe and define relationships
established among groups among
individuals between self and
supernatural Authority religion names
relationships between self and gods they
might say rather than take up an
exegesis today of that particular term
religion however
I would say in the majority of my
scholarship my interests in less and
theorizing the object religion to begin
than to take another object seemingly
either far-flung or somewhat proximate
but different and look at that
so today the object I want to nominate
because I think it's useful he brought
into a conversation on the religious now
is parenting the history of parenting is
a relatively recent history of inquiry
since parenting as a self-conscious
practice of cultivation is an artifact
of modernity prior to the 20th century
the verb to parent appeared very rarely
in the English lexicon as a noun it
referred almost exclusively to a
genealogical description before the 19th
century few indications of parenting as
a practice of cultivation exist was an
exponential increase in such usage after
the 1920s what I want to talk about is
how this shift took place under what
terms at the most generic level we can
agree that the parent is an emblem of
modernity and so far as parenting is a
matrix through which individuals
reckoned with the concepts of
individuality social participation and
moral consciousness
despite the rich terrain for cultural
observation the parenting practices
offer parenting is a very strange
lacunae in humanist analysis there is a
scholarly literature about published
child care advice about the changing
role of the mother about the social
history of the family and the cultural
meaning of the child
yet there is very little about the
concepts of parental control or
practices of parenting within us
religious history scholars have paid
very little attention to the religious
dimensions of modern family life despite
the practical and ideological
connections between religious ideation
and concepts of parental authority in
general there seems to be a sense that
religion particularly Protestant
Christianity in America once played a
very powerful job and role in the work
of parenting but that religion largely
disappeared from homes in the close at
the close of the Victorian era according
to the majority
of historical accounts religion within
the family like religion within the rest
of modernity disappeared in a
presumptive secularization such a
narrative depends on certain so
theologies of religion including those
that emphasize church attendance or
creedal adherence to prove a declension
yet I want to reimagine today with you
the history of parenting as a document
of religion in a broader sense one that
emphasizes how parenting and the
formation of a family unit defined by
its practice has increasingly become the
definitive religious focus of 20th and
21st century Americans persistent
throughout the documentary evidence
prescribing American parenting practice
is authority descriptions of the
authority of parents and the meaning of
that authority for the propagation of
the right society to be sure Romans and
Vikings parented Shakespeare's England
had parents but in the American context
parenting becomes an elaborate
discursive regime a Sian fee of parentis
this is me that propounded a potent
identity for its practitioners and a
social politics for everybody to debate
due in no small parts of the country's
colonial origins and its overthrow of
them due in no small part to its
relationship to parents parenting became
a telling subject in the new nation as
Alexis de Tocqueville observed of
America in 1840 when the social state
becomes democratic and men adopt as a
general principle that it is good and
legitimate to judge all things in
relation to oneself taking old beliefs
as information and not as rule the power
of opinion that a father exerts over his
son diminishes as does his legal power
the Tocqueville here speaks about the
diminishing potency of the father in the
in America elsewhere in his Texas some
of you know he writes about America's
multiplying and Tim quite strange
excessive religious communities I linked
these two subjects fading forms of
patriarchy increasing forms of religious
creativity
found together unfettered from mother
churches and father lands America
instantiated parental authority in a
prescriptive excess when authority is
diffused even invisible it must be
constructed to exist to observers of the
nascent country America was a vast
frontier the lack the scaffolding of
coherent Authority parenting and the
literature's which emphasized its
importance offered maps to this
seemingly wrongly mapless terrain to be
clear of course at any given time
parenting might be manifested in any
number of ways in any given time few
parents would hew neatly to some
prescriptive document what I want to
underline it's not a phenomenological
truth but an ontological one namely that
parents become the manifestation of
authority and recommendations about
parenting were recommendations about
proper self governance within such an
open atmosphere and as critics of
religion and psychologists of the family
have suggested the parental relation can
easily be figured analogously to their
religious relation an indicative 1882
treatise on moral education of children
American psychologist G Stanley Hall
would write in a much longer rhapsodic
passage he which I here abbreviate the
mother's face and voice are the first
conscious objects as the infant soul
unfolds and she soon comes to stand in
the very place of God to her child Hall
believed that in infancy individuals
developed a relationship to their
nurturing adults akin to that of divine
care inferred from such an observation
is an ongoing corollary between the
parental relationship and subsequent
divine engagement in that infant's life
in the history of psychology the parent
often represents a divine proxy adjust
parent like adjust God would inspire
individuals to ascend beyond the
primitive projections of a retributive
authority and instead pursue the good by
their own well-trained compass all of
this developmental theology occurs
around American cribs while Authority
itself is declining as a meaningful
religious concept here we see Barbara
Defoe Whitehead a vice president of the
conservative Institute for American
values who observe
in 1995 there has been a debunking of
leaders in our society turning away from
clergy and religious institutions and
while Whitehead has a tendency oh and
unhappy view of this epistemological
observation I agree with it
sociologically and it seems right to me
to describe the relationship between
religious institutions and the religious
believer in America as a disobedient one
so much so that this obedience itself
defines the permeable frames of our
religious experience one way to
summarize this is to say that religious
believers in America have become less
Orthodox not that there are fewer
self-identified religious adherents but
that the religions themselves have
become less invested in questions of
heresy dogma for example surveys over
the last 50 years have documented the
diminishment in certain forms of
retributive deities three-quarters
seventy-five percent of adolescents in
1961 believe that God punished people
who sinned this statistic fell by 1975
to slightly more than half and today the
numbers of Americans who believe God is
a punishing agent active in their
existence is statistically negligible
what I want to point to today is how
certain forms of divine ecclesiastical
and religious authority have diminished
while parental work and responsibilities
seem to have increased there has been a
persistent relationship between
religious ideation and parental
religious practice in the 20th century
one sociologist the massive study of
this in the mid-1990s and he found that
75 percent of Protestants left their
churches during late adolescence sort of
pubescent rebellion against their father
churches but then he remarked having
children is the number one impetus
people then have for returning or coming
back to their church or synagogue
49 percent of those same surveyed
returned to church in their late 30s in
response to having had children a 2007
survey by Parents magazine agree finding
that 64% of parents interviewed claimed
that they were more religious /
spiritual
since becoming a parent these examples
offer kind of suggestive sociology of
American parenting and its spiritual
connotations the sense of a need for
something else to be there as I do this
thing so concentrated in the remaining
space of this talk I'm going to consider
connections between the religious
history of the United States and its
cultural ideologies of parenting and as
I do this I'm not going to refer a lot
to the way that sectarian groups
prescribe very particular parenting
strategies for example like the
latter-day saint recommendation of a
family home evening or the hindu
practice of talking about vedic precepts
during everyday life instead what I want
to do is consider the way parenting is
figuring centrally and discussions of
American life especially as Americans
struggle with the questions of what kind
of individual will be the most
successful in changing religious
imperatives and market concerns
parenting concerns all the biggest
issues of existence other Ness community
freedom responsibility critique
interpretation love what I want to track
is how we came to embrace parenting as
one of the richest discursive spaces for
the consideration of these questions in
public I will move through an account of
the history of parenting at a clip
previously unseen that gathers its
conceits into interpretive clusters
including we're on a hustle people and
we're gonna go from colonial republican
hygienic industrial and service rapidly
moving to the present in an effort to
try to provide summary descriptions from
various literature's educational moral
scientific creating they slip into a
kind of a fantasy ascription what can we
really know from such a fantasy of
scripted from a kind of description of
the ideal parent what we know is
something very spectral I'm mindful as a
historian how can we know from a manual
of existence pretty much nothing
it's the actuality of existence yet I
think we can know quite a great deal
about the spectral concept of the terms
of my adjudication notably absent yet
presence in a way that we will see
is the rich material and consequential
racial history of parenting a history
that would necessarily include the
invocation of native-american relocation
slave families immigrants and refugees
as well as the specific analyses of
differential access to the very
institutional and governmental resources
I will be highlighting as supporting
these sort of icons and ideologies this
is a story that does not tell those
stories this is as typical in the
beginning of a plot this is a story that
focuses on a bushwa mentality that I
make iconic of the story that plots us
from Kathryn Beecher to miss Ann Romney
and G Stanley Hall to mr. dr. James
Dobson this is a broad genealogy of a
collective largely white will about
parenting in America if the absence of
parents define the beginning of American
history parental presence defined in
various ways American success and the
moral consequences of that success from
the 18th century to the 21st and now we
begin in the 17th and 18th century
America etiquette manuals and moral
treatises constantly seem to define and
liken the relationship between parents
and children in hierarchical terms quite
reminiscent of a colonial relationship
here are two quotations 1712 Benjamin
wodsworth writes children should
patiently wear and grow better by the
needful chastisements and corrections
their parents give them a 1768 treatise
said two children grumble not nor be
discontented at anything thy parents
appoint speak or do parents had one job
to break the will of their children so
that they would become adults who would
sacrifice their personal desires for the
good of the larger circles of authority
they occupied including those of family
church king and country British
colonists did not interpret
individualism or ambition as positive
aspects of a child's disposition to be
fostered rather they believed that
children were innately sinful and
required the controlling authority of a
parent to teach them self-discipline a
revolution in parenting transpired
simultaneously with the American
Revolution
in the early national period our
contemporary conceptions of child
nurture began to take shape as tandy
most significantly about and children
were increasingly understood to be less
sinful indeed children began to be
enchanted by a parental dynamic bent
upon pressing the family into political
significance Catherine Beecher one of
the foremost theorists of 19th century
domesticity female and otherwise
dedicated her 1869 volume the American
woman's home - this is her language the
women of America in whose hands rest the
real destinies of the Republic mothers
directed Republican parenting as fathers
guided Republican economic independence
each one relied on the other for its
perpetuation
despite this clarity about the NATO
importance of the American home the
available child-rearing manuals offered
a set of very conflicting demands the
parents a pattern to be continued
parents were told teach your children to
submit to a Christian conscience at the
same time circulating cultural images
emphasized the importance of free market
savvy and as one of them said a fierce
will for American success from the
standpoint of religious history this
contradictory endorsement of individual
independence and Christian obedience can
be seen across the American landscape as
schismatic sex forms by the month and
non-denominational evangelical
benevolent societies increased in number
and size a new circulating
interdenominational concept of national
Christianity became a form of Thorat
Aryan speech that inspired everything
from the new enshrinement of the mother
as a societal arbiter to the
abolitionist arguments focused on the
terrifying domestic familial
displacements of enslavement such a
presumptively Christian configuration
for family life was not met with
universal acclaim many if not all 19th
century communitarian critiques of exist
at religious authority like those
supplied by the latter-day saints the
ratites
the united perfectionists all included
centrally indictments of this nuclear
family and its norms for sexual practice
and gender identity across the country
individuals resisted this new Protestant
American rectitude in favor of
experimenting with very relatively new
prescriptions about right parents
families marriages whatever parental
authority that Christian observers
prescribed to quell indulgence
sensibilities there was also an equal
cultural tug to encourage rebellion and
that marvelously Republican child as
seen in the multiple depictions of the
impish child pulling pranks on mom dad
servants whatnot
and the confused results redeemed to be
thoroughly American from one European
observer parents love their children as
dearly and intensely as Europe but
exercise less control less Authority
American parents are far more forbearing
nay meeker with their children than they
are in Europe the invention of this
Republican nurturing parent had not it
seemed produced a child willing to be
controlled if Republican parenting
sought to instantiate a right citizen
lively wakeful angry ready
hygienic parenting sought to construct
the developmental apex of civilization
children ought to receive the very best
that science had to offer and they ought
to to embody physically and morally the
very best humankind humankind can be in
practice these two forces moral and
scientific were much more overlapping
and oppositional for example in the book
the Christian family psychologist George
Wolcott Walker fist argued for a
child-centered home that was run by his
language constructive discipline this
home would include a regular family
council as well as regular times for
prayer worship instruction when he was
trying to reach though for a metaphor to
describe this ideal familial community
Fiske wrote that the home was his
language a laboratory a place where
children could daily observe different
practices of religion and learned the
right ones through godly parenting the
home became a scientific laboratory due
in part to the permeating effects of the
child's study movement led by American
psychologist G Stanley Hall the Child
Study movement sought to enlist large
numbers of ordinary citizens in a broad
effort to deepen both public
and scientific understanding of human
development the child study movement
offered critical data for the advocacy's
of the social purity and the social
hygiene movements which connected
concepts of moral virtue to physical
practices these movements included the
distribution of bathing manuals to new
immigrant communities political
arguments on behalf of birth control
campaigns to outlaw prostitution and
eugenics propositions during the turn
from the 19th to the 20th centuries
scientists became more engaged in the
public sphere
and the wake of World War one scientific
evidence became the critical component
of any federal legislative action moral
hygiene laws evinced a Christian
moralism still at work in American
jurisprudence offering new sociological
and medical data as a kind of social
perfectionism that might resolve the
bodies of all those unwashed masses
coming to shore this is when we can see
a financier parentis becoming thoroughly
identifiable a rash of new child-rearing
manuals began to appear in the United
States in the 1920s as one prominent
historian of the American family has
argued the 20th century described as the
century of the child became their
language a century of anxiety about the
child and the parents own anxiety the
number of agencies and manuals devoted
to children and their proper care
increased exponentially as the author of
religious education of the family
described today's parents are becoming
more and more interested in the rational
performance of high duties and formed in
their forming associations in church
Christian associations women's clubs and
Institute's are studying the subject
there is a general desire for guidance
this organizational development
surrounding the subject of parenting
reflected the expanding national culture
of Education the incursion of
therapeutic idiom in all of public life
and the formation of federal agencies to
nurture and monitor human welfare
hygienic parenting was a very potent
discourse one that identified the child
as a primitive subject to be developed
into a civilized adulthood in a process
of recapitulation evocative of the very
worst
excesses of social Darwinism yet these
arguments would not persist in precisely
that form the scientism became an excess
and a rebuttal emerged as happens in
every transition in my plot as historian
Martha wolfenstein has spoken about the
transition in the 1920s and 1930s was
that there was a transformation in the
conception of the child that was a
rebuttal against this kind of endless
measuring and monitoring of the child's
particularity this is her language where
formerly the mother was to exercise a
ceaseless vigilance removing the thumb
from the child's mouth as often as he
put it in now she is told wolfenstein
explained not to make a fuss to let the
child act without interruption if
hygienic Parenthood required the
persistent correction and moral
devotions of the physical development of
her child
the new iteration of parenting
recommended offered a kind of mandate
that the parent not merely raised their
child carefully particularly with great
detail but also that the parent take
pleasure in their child naughty or nice
parenting became and this is Wolfenstein
locution a practice of fun morality the
test of your parenting was no longer
your child but whether you lived a life
devoted to the fabulous enjoyment of
your child if Republican heir parenting
emphasized the creation of able citizens
and hygienic parenting moulded civilized
subjects industrial parents focus their
energies on creating a massive
population of capitalist consumers who
could outnumber outspend any Cold War
enemy the industrial parent used the
exponentially increasing array of
consumer packaged goods to tend to every
part of a child's physicality and
intellectual development they were
handmaidens of the military-industrial
complex transferring the post-war
productivity to a very intimate
homefront following World War two it
seemed that everything in the American
landscape existed to foster children and
their parents tracked homes automobiles
highway infrastructure in home
furnishings public schools industry
worked overtime to supply the material
context for the material is
of this the definitive baby boom
countless incentives from federally
financed mortgages to tax deductions
supported the establishment of nuclear
families with children
the birth rate rose among all social
occupational economic and ethnic groups
and a remarkable consensus of
reproductive behavior communities like
Levittown Pennsylvania earned the
nicknames fertility Valley and the
rabbit hutch to describe their natal
excess although the baby boom was filled
in part by the post-war economic boom it
also resulted in a profound change in
the national political culture
Parenthood now became an absorbing
creative profession a career second to
none wrote one writer in 1946 this is a
very single transition in my historical
account as it is when exterior
authorities moral and hygienic become
internalized by the parents when dr.
Spock remarked trust yourself you know
more than you think you do he
effectively concluded the era of
hygienic parenting turning from outside
scientific authorities toward the
analysis of their own maternal and
paternal feelings this did not however
diminish the role of parenting manuals
or their authors rather it's going to
elaborate the role of the author as an
interpretive guide to those unexplored
parental feelings as families live in
increasingly atomized physical settings
child really manual met authors became
virtual vigil village elders boon
companions and confessors to those who
bought their texts and consider the
application of their complex
recommendations to me this is a very
significant transition and the history
of self and other the parenting gurus
Spock or otherwise existed mainly to
help the parent to help themselves to
see what it is the child wanted most to
be in to do the purpose of parenting was
to come to understand your child as they
were not to compel them to formal rules
or abstract metrics for 52 years sales
of dr. Benjamin Spock's baby and child
care were second only to the Bible in
the United States this engagement with a
child was spot argued the absolute
highest calling him
taking care of their children seeing
them grow and develop into fine people
gives most parents despite the hard work
their greatest satisfaction in life it
is a creative and generative act on
every level
pride and other worldly accomplishments
usually pales in comparison in the world
of dr. Spock there is no such thing as a
willful child there's only 8
misunderstood child his handbook
included short recommendations usually
two to three paragraphs in length about
every conceivable childcare question
posed often and some of you probably
know this as a series of questions to
the parent this passage I'm about to
show you a passage I'm like building up
to a reveal if you haven't seen it
you're just in for a treat today
so every as you read this passage keep
in mind that to me what's interesting
about it is it's sort of hung that the
text has a kind of hum that I would I
would myself on a very much like into
meditative transitions but we'll hold
that back for the Q&A for right now
notice the responsibilities of the
parent the kind of interactions that are
made ideal between parent and child the
critical role material goods play and
the management of a child's disposition
and the question who is the boss
frequent tantrums are most often due to
the fact that the parents haven't
learned the knack of handling this
behavior tactfully if your child is
having frequent temper tantrums ask
yourself the following questions
does she have plenty of chance to play
freely outdoors are there things for her
to push and pull and climb on there
indoors has she had enough toys and
household objects to play with and is
the house child proofed do you without
realizing it aroused bulkiness by
telling her to come and get her shirt on
instead of slipping it on without
comment or asking her she wants to go to
the bathroom instead of leading her
there or bringing the potty to her when
you have to interrupt her to play to get
her in doors or meals do you frustrate
her directly or get her mind on
something pleasant when you see a storm
brewing do you meet it head-on
grimly or you distract her to something
else time and again
Spock's ideas were described Reposado
Klee with enormous relief as common
sense and they quickly pervaded the
landscape parents referred to their
children as Spock babies with pride a
pull of more than a thousand new mothers
found at 64% of them
had red baby in childcare 30 years after
the book was released of this group four
of every five referred to the book at
least twice a month doctors and
insurance agents gave it away for free
well into the 70s with every birth dr.
Spock becomes a national paterfamilias
whose wisdom emanates from a kind of set
of Commandments he argued that parents
could achieve enlightenment through the
admirable patience and quiet labor of
submissive parenting Spock was the ideal
mouthpiece for industrial parenting his
parent was the assembly line laborer
possessing a stoic constancy before a
job described as necessary necessarily
hard but constantly revelatory not
everybody affirmed
Spock's view conservative columnist
Stewart Alsop complained that an entire
generation was sparked when they should
have been spanked later Evan Jellicle
psychologist James Dobson would author
his book titled dare to discipline as a
countermeasure to the leniency
identified in Spock debate about
parental authority was a debate in part
about what political arrangement the
practitioner preferred during the late
20th century conservative political
leaders increasingly align themselves
with conservative religious leaders
developing an argument about family life
and family values that was they claimed
a metonym for right governance meanwhile
an expanding parade of child care gurus
would offer nurturing descriptions of
children for working mothers and fathers
trying to cultivate right relations with
their child as they also sought to
survive the changing market world the
industrial parent had produced a
generation of children appropriate to
the increasingly consumer Republic and a
generation of children disaffected from
any other Authority other than their own
the late 20th century parent was is
we'll talk about that in the Q&A and
service to the child managing and
strategizing every aspect of their
person to maximize their market
potential during the 1990s
several critical economic and
demographic shifts took place that would
affect the practice of parenting
including the rampant expansion of
American higher education the
outsourcing of industry
and the corresponding transition to an
information economy and profound
reapportionments of gender demographics
in all occupations with an increase in
standards of living and educational
access American children live lives a
profound material Plenty when compared
to their historical predecessors this
improvement in children's lives led to
an escalation of the minimal standard
for a child's well-being meanwhile the
ubiquity of mass entertainment brought
new anxieties about cultural experience
and mental development and a decline in
child labour raised questions about the
function and identity of children
depending on your Vantage and this is a
quote two quotes contemporary American
kids may represent the most indulged
people in the history of the world or
they may be understood as the most
pressure young people in the history of
the world certainly parents have been
figured as responsible for the results
of this excess and as one child
psychologist commented never before have
parents been so convinced that their
every move has a ripple effect into
their child's future success who
commented to these shifts in children's
culture were significant alterations in
religious life more and more Americans
identified themselves as spiritual not
religious an incantation that included
both those free-thinking participants in
the New Age movement and attendance at
nondenominational Christian services
what unites a very diverse spectrum of
believers is the disavowal of the
nomination for more and more Americans
being religious meant something
disconnected from institutions and
authorities the practice of religion is
now a looser concept comprised of
reading groups therapeutic practices and
the combinatory of sectarian ideas a
1995 article for example in Parents
magazine outlined the spiritual values
parents a relatively secular outfit
spiritual values that every parent
should insert into family activities
here's the list select the congregation
that matches your family's needs and
personality set aside some time every
week for sacred family time teach kids
tolerance introduce your children to
different faiths by taking them to
interface
services or activities in your community
answer big questions directly and
finally when children ask about good and
evil birth or death don't we reply with
a complicated physiological response
these values did not belong to any
single Creed they seemed to be presented
as two generally agreed upon moral
middle of a presumptively plural society
and so as the terms of parental success
were increasingly narrow to educational
ascendance but terms of religious
articulation became purposefully vaguer
determine by the needs of the believer
and the needs of the whole family
another article in another parenting
magazine described that the most
successful churches and synagogues
envision their connotations not as a
center for theological debate or
discussion or as a center for ritual
practice but as the language a hub for a
network of families churches will not
succeed if they focus on theology or
doctrine they succeed if they provide
activities that meet the needs of young
families and not this article concludes
the other way around within this culture
of religious fluidity and parental
ambition a very strange subject of
parenting took center stage very briefly
in the mid to late 90s since the 1970s
the divide between parent centered
practice and child centered practice was
increasingly determined by a presumptive
religious identity child centered
proselytizer like berry Brazelton and
Penelope leach were avowedly secular
advocates of parental practices of
listening loving learning interacting
whereas the self proclaimed
judeo-christian experts such as James
Dobson the william damon loudly
condemned what they saw as the decadent
state of american culture arguing for a
disciplining parent in an era of service
parenting this dichotomy achieved
notoriety in the 1990s when the corporal
punishment of children became a topic of
heated social and political debate a
massive scholarly effort replied to data
that suggested conservative Protestants
were more likely than other parents to
value obedience from their children and
use corporal punishment to do so
spanking in particular became a public
object a state of emergency took place
and reply as
dollars scrambled to assemble evidence
from research on the physical discipline
of children to prove that corporal
punishment was ineffective at deterring
child misbehavior and that children
subjected to corporal punishment tended
to be more aggressive with peers than
children who experience alternative
forms of discipline what to me is very
peculiar about this blip of reactive
social science is twofold first the
available empirical evidence did not
suggest that Christian parents did in
fact use corporal punishment only that
some of their childcare manuals
recommended that a light tap on the
bottom could get what you wanted
second and more importantly the broader
demography of American religion largely
turning as it was away from such modes
made coverage of this kind of marginal
biblical readings very disproportionate
to the sociological real yet if early
20th century social scientists sought to
combine moral programming with
scientific recommendation late 20th
century social scientists seemed bent
upon exiling all forms of religion from
cultural practice as if religion was the
last false Authority left to the
liberation of the happy and healthy
parent but the parent can't be so easily
freed and the problem of parenting
didn't go away if corporal punishment
was itself largely as it was in the
public sphere reviled perhaps this
reaction to marginal Protestant parental
practice was a red herring in the late
1990s parents and experts struggled with
much bigger dramas as there were
increased incidents of violence enacted
by children and teenagers talk of
spanking Protestants may have been a
kind of convenient sacrificial object
for a public lacking answers about the
expansion and Youth pharmacology the
increase in school shootings juvenile
depression and diagnosis is ADV and ADHD
if religion could just be the culprit
then the cure could be simple less
religion more parenting if religion
wasn't the only problem then giving all
the existing literature on child nurture
for all of those problems
ADHD violence parents had only
themselves to blame looking back from
this era of service parenting to those
that preceded it it's possible to make
several now broad claims about the
relationship between religion and
American parenting at the same time that
there has been argue a diminishment in
cradle orthodoxies the expectations of
what it means to be a parent have become
more orthodox not that parents are more
religious but that more people are
treating parenting religiously relatedly
there are more areas of imagined
perfection within a frame of child
development of course no parent can
claim to be comprehensive or ideal in
their parenting but all parents would
speak now of parenting is an
occupational force in their lives being
a parent today isn't just a component of
existence but an ordering fact of it one
which seems to press at the limits of
sanity wellness time budget ability
parenting has become the determinate of
calling for late modern adults examples
from the disputes often electoral of
summer 2012 illustrate the contradictory
positions held within this new landscape
of nurturance during that time it was
difficult to avoid the subject of
parenting largely exhibited through the
complicated and fraught figure of the
mother here to two quotations from both
of the candidates wives speaking about
the centrality of their motherhood as
their capacity to leave in the early
20th century the elements of infant
nurture have gone decidedly public
including entire economies psychologies
and lobbies dividing the world between
good and bad parents depending on the
practices that they pursue amid the din
of debate though about toddler
breastfeeding and super mothers about
nannies quality time about the news
slacker dads and the old midwifery I am
trying to nominate all of these topics
as topics for the study of religion
because to me there's one hum of truth
in all of these subjects that practicing
parenting is central to the American
moral life determinative of the American
moral imagination in the mid-1990s
Parents magazine surveyed more than 77
thousand seven hundred readers and found
that there was a universal agreement
that teaching children was the practical
way to make a lasting contribution to
society Elaine Tyler man
story was written quite a bit on
childlessness worries about this she
writes many Americans believe that the
only place they can find true happiness
is in private life
this belief traces an overwhelming
burden as well as an overwhelming sense
of experience expectation on individual
procreative behavior as determinative of
the moral life in a moment which the
public's fear seems unwieldy and maybe
undisciplined being a parent seems
perhaps the only way to change the world
our religious history of American
parenting shows that there has not been
a secularization of the American family
in which religion has increasingly
absent in itself instead this history
shows that parenting provides a mode of
religious expression if religious
orthodoxy is understood as a submission
of individuals to a comprehensive
theological system parental orthodoxy
could be conceived as a submission of
individuals to the work of parenting as
determining the lives of its
practitioners the home I argue has not
become merely a replacement for the
church it has become the genesis of the
secular that defines our religious world
scholarship that tries to tackle the
embodied material and social facts of
this dynamic would offer not only
portraits of the history of the family
but also I think key exhibits in the
history of religions thank you so much